und wir schauen auf eine klaren
Schießerei und das mitten in Berlin ja
besser noch direkt neben der Polizei
Direktion im Berliner Bezirk Wedding da
haben Unbekannte aus einem fahrenden
Auto herausgeschossen ein Mann ist
schwer verletzt worden man sieht ein
Schuss Löcher vier Schüsse waren es die
haben die Fenster einer Wohnung im
Erdgeschoss durchschlagen und sind in
der Hauswand dann stecken geblieben
direkt an den Tatort jetzt zu unserem
BILD-Reporter Benjamin trampf Schüsse
aus einem Auto heraus wie hat sich diese
Tatort im Berliner Clan Milieu
vermutlich abgespielt
genau hier ist es gestern Abend passiert
in Berlin Gesundbrunnen wir befinden uns
auf der Pankstraße Höhe der Hausnummer
25 und genau hier fallen gestern Abend
diese vier Schüsse die vermeintliche
Wohnungen es handelt sich hierbei um
eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft diese vier Schüsse
durchschlagen diese blickdichten
Scheiben der Rezeption schlagen ins
Innere einbleiben in der Wand hinten
stecken sollen einen vermeintliches Clan
Mitglied Treffen dieser Mann wird auch
verletzt ein weiterer Mann ebenfalls
verletzt vermutlich sein Begleiter diese
vier Schüsse wir haben gerade eben auch
mit einigen Flüchtlingen sprechen können
drei davon waren im Hinterhof gerade
haben ein bisschen in der Sonne gesessen
und sich ausgetauscht über die
Ergebnisse des gestrigen Abends über die
Geschehnisse die da stattgefunden haben
zwei Personen waren zu diesem Zeitpunkt
gar nicht vor Ort eine weitere in einem
weiteren Trakt untergebracht die haben
also glücklicherweise nichts mitgekriegt
aber das beschäftigt sie natürlich ne
die kommen aus dem Krieg aus der Ukraine
gerade hierher und dann fallen wieder
Schüsse in der vermeintlich neuen
sicheren Unterkunft mit den Polizisten
haben wir auch ganz kurz sprechen können
die Waren zu keiner Aussage bereit die
sichern hier momentan noch die Spuren
sichern diesen Tatort ab zu dem es
gestern Abend gegen 20 Uhr zur
vierschüssen kamen kaltblütig hier auf
offener Straße momentan die Straße die
Pankstraße nicht sehr belebt die Berlin
und Brandenburger die hier in der Stadt
Arbeiten befinden sich momentan bei der
Arbeit die Kinder in der Schule die
Schulferien sind beendet aber gestern um
diese Zeit das hat uns der Polizist
zumindest sagen können ist hier weitaus
mehr los dann kommen die Leute von der
Arbeit mit ihren Einkäufen
beispielsweise wieder nach Hause die
Schulkinder freuen sich dass die Schule
vorbei ist kommt vielleicht vom Spielen
und da war weitaus mehr hier los und
diese Kaltblütigkeit diese 30igkeit nur
wenige Meter entfernt wir können ja mal
ein paar Meter weiter fahren befindet
sich die Polizei Direktion eins hier in
Berlin Gesundbrunnen das sind wirklich
nur ein paar
ja noch halten die Ermittler natürlich
aus ermittlungstaktischen Gründen
Informationen zurück welche Clans jetzt
bei dieser schießereibeteiligt sind
tatsache aber ist die verschiedenen
Clans in Berlin in ganz Deutschland sie
bestimmen fast schon im Wochentag die
Schlagzeilen um welche Familien handelt
es sich dabei wer sind diese
Großfamilien die das Recht in die eigene
Hand nehmen
der Abu chaka-clan der Clan hat einen
palästinensischen Hintergrund sein
Oberhaupt Arafat Abu Chaka der
abou-chaker-clan ist zahlenmäßig mit
mehreren hundert Mitgliedern eher das
Schlusslicht dafür ist er wahrscheinlich
am bekanntesten zu ihrem zweifelhaften
Ruhm gelangte die Familie vor allem
durch ihre Verwicklung in die
deutschrap-szene und Arafats Zerwürfnis
mit dem Rapper Bushido dessen Management
er lange übernommen hatte der remo-clan
der Clan hat einen arabischen
Migrationshintergrund clan-oberhaupt ist
Issa Remo mit 500 bis 1000 Mitgliedern
zählt er hier eher zu den kleinen Clans
aber unterschätzen sollte man die
Großfamilie nicht unter anderem sollen
sie für den Einbruch in die Dresdner
Schatzkammer grünes Gewölbe und den Raub
der Goldmünze aus dem Berliner
Bode-Museum verantwortlich sein der
miri-clan er kommt aus dem Libanon und
ist vor allem in Niedersachsen vertreten
planbos ist ibrahimiri weit über zwei
Dutzend türkisch libanesische Familien
gehören zu den Miris und so besteht er
aus mehr als 1.000 Mitgliedern dem Clan
werden schwere Fälle von Drogenhandel
Diebstahl und Hehlerei vorgeworfen der
all seinen Plan der Plan ist eine
weitverzweigte kootisch-arabische
Großfamilie der clanbus moormut als sein
der mittlerweile in der Türkei lebt mehr
als 10.000 Mitglieder hat der Clan
illegale Geschäfte mit Drogen und Waffen
zu hälterei Geldwäsche Körperverletzung
Betrug und Diebstahl sollen zur
Tagesordnung des allseinplans gehören
außerdem soll der Clan auch in den
Einbruch in die juwelierabteilung des
Berliner KaDeWe verwickelt gewesen sein
[Musik]